Bir
[Alkış]
dahaki de iyi günler Umarım herkes
kendisi için faydalı bir gün geçirir
Teşekkürler davet ettiğin için bu arada
şimdi
Şimdi minik minik bir şey okuyarak
başlamak istiyorum dediğinizde sonra
bırakacağım telefonu
başka olasılıkları hayal edin farklı
deneyin önyargılı fikirlerden kurtulup
ufkun ötesinde bakın Yeni Bir Dünya
keşfedin
de hemen konuyu
acaba bütün Bu söylediklerim hangi
aktivitede yer alır
ve sanat yaparken bütün bu yazar Her şey
sanat yaparken bir yaşadıklarınızı
sahasında Çünkü bilmediğiniz bir şey
için yola çıkıyorsunuz O hayal
ediyorsunuz önünüzde bir çok problem
çıkıyor o problemleri devamlı burada
çıkan problemler çoğunu da kendi
yarattığımız problemler hayallerimizin
yarattığı Problemler yok problemleri
çözmek için yaratıcı çözümler
vuruyorsunuz bunu bulurken ne
kullanıyoruz
ellerimizi ayaklarımızı vücudumuzu
fiziğiniz dedi
duygularımızı Bıdı düşüncelerimizi bütün
tecrübeleriniz sanatın en muhteşem yanı
kendinizi Tam kapasite kullandığımız bir
an yaratıyor ve bu an o kadar değerli ki
sanat için değerli değil ama sizin için
değerli Çünkü ilerde bu ufukta
bilmediğiniz yolculukta
ihtiyacınız olan birçok şeyi sanat
yaparken geliştirmez anlamına geliyor
çünkü
en büyük bir haksızlık olduğunu
söyleyeyim 18 yaşında 19 yaşında
Gencecik
kalbi aşkla dolu sevdiklerine göre dik
hayatı bilmeyen yenilerine olacağını
bilmeyen Gencecik insanlara hayatı
boyunca yapacağım meslekler ise çekmeye
çalışıyoruz Bu çok büyük bir haksızlık
Ben çevremde çok sayıda insan biliyorum
yaptığı mesleği iyi sevmiyor ama yapmak
zorunda çok çok az insan biliyorum
yaptığı mesleği severek yapıyor bu
konuda çok şanslıyım Çünkü İnanamadık
yine dayanılmaz geleceğiz Evde yaptığım
ve inanarak yaptığı mesleğin var
çocuklarla gençlerle sanat yapmak Ama
bunun ötesinde o zevkle yapan hani tam
ihtiyaçlarını bulmuş o ufkun ötesinde ki
mutlulukla yeşil yapacağı bir mesleği
buluş kişilerde neredeyse 199u şans
eseri bunu bulmuş oluyor Yani büyük bir
Piyango önünüzde şu anda bu geleceği
öğrenmeniz edebilmemiz mümkün değil ama
burada vereceğimiz kararlar da o
yaşayacağımız o 100.yol yaşayacağımız
süreçte en güzel şey Kendimizi
geliştirmek ben çok sonuna kadar
inanıyorum ki sana bu anlamda inanılmaz
şeyler veriyor Kendimizi geliştirmek
için ve o yaşayacağız yolunda esası
minik bir kısa süreli her yer sanat
yaptığınız yaşınız kısa süreli denemesi
bilmediğiniz bir yola çıkıyorsunuz her
adımda gerekli çözümleri buluyorsunuz
ilerliyorsunuz sonucunda yaptığınızı
beğenirseniz En güzeli o zaman demek ki
başarılı bir süreç gerçekleşmiş oluyor
bir döngü tamamlanıyor hiç bilmediği bir
şey hayal edip oturup onu yapıp
yaptıktan sonra beğendiğiniz de o biten
başarılı döngünün sonucunda herkes yapan
kişi kendisini başarılı hissetmeye
başlıyor Bence bu hiç Çok önemli çünkü
gelecekti adımlar atarken özgüvenli
olmak 12'nin farkında olmak
farklılığının farkında olmak
becerilerini geliştirmiş olarak orada
olmak çok yakı
o cümle var Bir iki çocuklu bir iki
kelimeden oluşuyor sonunda şey yani ne
olduğunu söylemiyorum o kadar muhteşem
bir cevap gel ne dedi biliyor musun
sanatını ne olduğunu cevap et o canı
gönülden yapılan şehir
yani ne olduğunu söylemiyorum ama nasıl
yapılması gerektiği konusunda inanılmaz
bir yol çiziyor canı gönülden yapılması
canı gönülden kelimesini en iyi hepiniz
duyduğunuz çok kullanmıyoruz ama benim
için sadece artık sanatın tanımı da
kullandığım bir kelime Çünkü içerse o
kadar çok şey var ki kuru Avrupa Birliği
projesi yapıyorduk ve projenin başında
bir iki üç kalsın var diye dünyadaki
İngilizcenin en yüksek otoritesi değil
mi Can gününden kelimesinin İngilizce'de
karşılığı yok Tek kelime olarak dökünüz
de Çünkü heyecan var hem dönüyor var her
şey var Her şeyini verir yaptığından
bahsediyor diliyorum ki hepimiz için
canı gönülden yapacağınız bilmezsiniz
olur şimdi sana da geldiğimizde bu canı
gönülden yapılan şeydir durumunda
çocuklarla Gençler bu çok terk edin
devamlı konuşuyorum hem isteyen sanatçı
olabildiği soruyorum
o cevap üzücü
385 civarı çocuk olmaz diyor çocuk
derken onu yaşlarda kasmıyorum 18'ler de
kadar çocuğu hepimiz
Oğlum niye ediyorum çünkü yetenekli
olmak lazım ya nasıl yapıyorum Hatta bir
dahaki doğuştan gelir yani doğduktan
sonra ben kızımın doğumundan ne yazık ki
bulunamadım erken doğdu ama doğduğumda
şöyle bir şey bu oluyor bilmiyorum
doğrular varsa öğretmenlerimiz azından
sorabiliriz belki doğduktan sonra bize
bir şaplak geçiriyoruz ağlatıyor Hoş
geldin ya ediyoruz sonra kenarda bir
profesör var mı Dene bakalım Tamam
Doğuştan yetenekli pop evde anlamı var
öyle bir durum yok kim karar verir
Doğuştan yetenekli oldu bu şimdi orada
yeteneği ne olduğu sorusu ortaya çıkıyor
onu sorun çocuklara cevap çocuklarda
Çünkü ben Gaziantep'te çıktı karşıma
böyle bir cevap verdi ki Hani bazen bir
durum olur ya Anne babamı çok kızıyoruz
çok çok güzel tamam tamam bir daha
yapmayacağım diye Bir Kenara çekilir ya
öyle bir durum oldu hatta 3 bu
Gaziantep'te devamlı bana çay ister
misin diyorsun ya ben de çayı sevmem
Teşekkürler almış çeşitli Ama bu hani
saatte üç defa fil oluyor Çocuk'u cevabı
verdikten sonra yine bütün sevdiğimi
eşek Elif diyorum Çünkü cevabı son şey o
cevap verdi dersin ki alayım çay Orada
öyle bir Tamam yaşadım ya çay içtim iki
katlı sevdiğim oyundur beni şekersiz
içine beraber söylediği şey şu bile
hareket de yap yani bir olayın verdiği
cevabın fiziksel bir karşıda şöyle yaptı
bana
Bende olan başkasını Olmayan şey
o bende olan başkasında Olmayan şey size
var mı o
bu Eğer bu 8 milyar civarı insanın
yaşadığı Dünyada sizden bir tane daha
yoksa
hepiniz de başka kimsede olmayan bir şey
var bu insan Burcu sevdiğin şey Her
doğan insanı farklı olarak doğası sanat
Burada şu anda çok değerli Çünkü o her
biri farklı olan dünyada bir tane daha
olmayan o insanların sonuna kadar
o istedikleri şekilde çalışabilecekleri
sonsuz bir alan suyu neredeyse
o istediği gibi bununla da sağlamasını
de yapabiliriz şöyle bir sağlama
yapıyorum Herkese aynı kağıdı verelim
Herkese aynı kalemlerin bütün dünyadaki
şekillerden bahsediyorum Herkese aynı
masa ve sandalye oturtalım ikiye herkese
yetecek kadar yapar ondan sonra değil ki
5 dakikanız var Ve konuyu da bilir
herkez balık çiçek Hatta onu da biraz
büyütüyorum diyelim ki hani balıkçının
vardı ya şöyle bir tek çizgiyle şöyle
balık Herkes bu şekilde balık çizecek
diyelim 8 milyar insan aynı masa
sandalye de aynı Kağıt aynı kalem 5
dakikada o Balıktan çizdikten sonra iki
tane aynı balık çıkar mı sorusu var
bu çıkar mı bu çıkmaz çıkarsa ilahi bir
mucize gerçekleşmiş olur Bunun sebebi de
kağıtta değil kalemde değil Masadaki
insanlarla değil bu sebebi Bizler de
farklı ve tek olmamızda ve sanatın o
kadar sınırlı anladığımıza rağmen o
kadar geniş bir alanda bize o
farklılığımız Doyasıya yaşayacağınız bir
alan bırakıyor olmasıdır bu yetenek
sınavı
şimdi Yetenek nedir diye konuştum sana
verdiği çocuk acaba Normalde esasında
bir çoğunuz aşınmış olabilir zeytinin
karşılığı Türkiye'de bir dünyanın birçok
yerinde bölgesi alsın ufak yaşlarda
başlar Neyi ne oldu siz benden daha iyi
diyorsunuz esasında gördüğü şeyi en çok
benzeterek çizen çocuk okulda
yeteneklidir sınıfta yeteneklidir bu
tahminin benzer tecrübesi ilkokuldan
beri yaşıyorsunuz değil mi Biz
yetişkinler böyle bir kurgu yapıyoruz
Çünkü ve her bütün için adına En azından
ben kendi adıma özür dilerim bundan
doğru çünkü çok yanlış bir yönde bu
gördüğümüz içecek yetenek olsaydı zaten
fotoğraf makinesi çıktıktan sonra
insanlar sanat yapmayı bırakmadı değil
mi Ama bırakmadılar çünkü başka bir şey
var orada sana o değil hatta Sanat nedir
diye çok soruyorum ya Herkese yetişkin
çocuk fark etmez şu ana kadar 50 binden
fazla insanı sormuşum dur yabancı bir
Türkiyeli hiç kimse bana şöyle bir
gördüğü şeyi çok iyi benzeterek yapmak
saatlerini kimseden herkes dedi ki
duygular düşünceler bir şeyler aktarmak
hiç kimse onu söylemedi ama çocukların
önündeki en büyük duvar gördüğüm en iyi
ki senin çocuğun yetenekli olup ki bu da
özellikle ilkokulda Sınıf içerisindeki
en önemli yıllar sınıf içen 30 kişilik
bir sınıfta 12 düşünseniz 30 kişilik bir
sınıfta her hafta bir iki kişi kendisini
yetenekli zannediyor mutlu oluyor
amacı kısmı 28 tane çocuk başarısız
yeteneksiz beceriksiz hissediyor
kendisini ve her hafta devamlı olarak
yaklaşık 8-10 yıl dertli daha fazla
sürüyor ve bu biz bu yaptığı çok yanlış
bir sistemin sanatla bağlantı bir
sisteminin mi çok çok kötü ya da
çocukların özgüvenini biraz gezen ve
onları gelecekte farklı adımlar atması
konusunda Tam da bu hani ufka gitme
yolunda esasında önüne taş koyan bir
yaklaşım O yüzden sanat yapın yapım ki
kendinizi geliştirin daha becerikli olun
daha Kıvrak zekalı onu Daha yaratıcı
düşünürsün yaratıcı düşünmek de çok
kolay kendini düşüneceksin sadece bilgi
Dayanmak zorunda değilsin kendin oraya
yaratıcı bir çözüm bulacaksın ve sanatta
zaten hemen her saniye yaptığım bir şey
o kadar kolay ki kalem kağıdı dokunun
nereye gidecek sağım solum aşağı yukarı
tek karar veriyoruz her an her sahibi
doğal bir şekilde karar veriyoruz ve
bütün bunun sonucunda da gerçekten
kendimizi geliştiririz bir süreç
yaşıyoruz O alanda Sizi gerçekten
tahsilim sanat yapmayı tırnak içerse
güzel şeyler yapmak için değil ama
kendinizi geliştirmek için yapıldı Bunu
Instagram'da gördüğüm zaman O çok
beğendim
bu muhteşem
ve hiçbir özelliği yok bu muhteşem Çünkü
sevgiyle yapıldı çok belli o Atın o
güzel yüzünü o inanılmaz farklı
bacakları çok çok etkili dedi ama
arkadaki bedava Üstüne para verseniz
almadık şu gerek yok fotoğraf çekinip
atıp uyumuna benzetmeye çalışayım ki ama
burada özel bir şey var Kendisinden bir
şey kalkmış bu yapamamak ile ilgili
değil köşeli Olabilir çünkü bu Bu arada
arkada at yok özür dilerim onu düzeltmem
lazım Biz yetişkinler sanıyoruz ki orada
at var at yok orada birinin hayalindeki
çizdiği at resmi var o aktif mi olduğu
zamanda köşeli de olur tek bacağı
incecik olur öbür bacak alın doğmuş
Çünkü bak yapmış Olmuş bazen şey diyoruz
Ben pembesinin dramı diyorum sen çocuk
resim yapıyor pembe bir fil yapıyor
Kanatlar takıyor götürür öğretmenleriyle
birlikte gösteriyor yetişkinlerin genel
tavrı nedir
pedifil olur mu pilin kanatları olur mu
şimdi bu o cevap olabilir ama ders Eğer
bir derste isek Eğer ders fil anatomisi
der size kabul ediyoruz ama doğru film
anatomisine göre Orada ev kanat olmalı
ama öldü dersin var mı yok herhalde diye
düşünüyorum sanat dersi yaratıcı
olduğumuz ufkumuzu genişletti biz bir
şey ise kanatlı da olur pembe dolu
Yeşilli olur diye düşünüyoruz Bu arada
bir olmaz görüş çocuğa karşımızda var
yapmış bu arada Hadi çocuğun da anlatı
olmaz diyor ben yapmıştım zaten diyor
Niye olmaz diyor gibi düşüncelerle varsa
aslında biz yetişkinler Biraz hızlı
büyüdüğümüz zaman ya hayatın yorucu
yanlarında geçmişimizi ve çocukluğumuzu
herhalde unutuyoruz bu unuttuğumuz için
bence bu problemler yaşıyor diye
düşünüyorum o yüzden sanat yapın
yaparken kendi sevdiğiniz şekilde yapın
başkasına beğendirmek çabasına girmeyin
kendinizi takviminin Çünkü o sırada
Özgüven gelişir beceriler gelişleri hem
zihinsel hem fiziksel duygularınızla i
bu bölümde olursunuz ve bunun sonucunda
çıkan iş gerçekten özel birşey dönüşür
bir çoğunuz bununla ilgili şu anda hani
biz evdeyiz çok geç gibi düşünüyor
hiçbir zaman geçtiği şu anda Türkiye'nin
en önemli vefat etmiş sonuçlarından bir
tanesi demek durumu ne yazık ki üzülerek
söylüyorum Burhan Doğançay var Türk
sanat tarihi önemli bir yeri var
eserlerini beğenirsiniz beğenmezsiniz o
size ait bir şey ama Burhan doğançay'ın
şöyle bir yanı var Bir çoğunuz bilmiyor
olabilir Bir Taksim tarafında bir tane
minik müzesi var Kendi kurduğu Babası da
ve Sam Hadi Askerliğe salmış beraber
eserlerin sergilendiği bir müjdesi var
Bu iyi bir şey daha söyleyeyim dünya
diğer Türkiye'deki en pahalı sanat eseri
en yüksek ve da Satılmış ki şayet zaman
kendisi ve Sanat Eğitim yok
hatta memuş Türkiye devletine çalışan
milli bulmuş ne orta gittikten sonra
orada memuriyet hayatına devam ederken
sanat yapmaya karar verip memur bu
bırakıyo hatta İşini bırakıp New York
gibi o dönemde de hem dünyanın sanat
merkezi ama sabahtan para kazanmak çok
zor Ona rağmen bırakıp beraber eşi de
var orada onu da destekliyor bırakıyoruz
saat yapıyor O anlamda çok çok değerli
bir şey
insanların verdiği kararları takip
edebilmesi orada bunu yapmış ve şu anda
Türkiye'de saat tarihinde önemli bir
yeri olan çok özel bir sanatçı dönüşmüş
bu lütfen ama lütfen
siz destekleyen insanları dinleyin ama
önünüze taşkoyan insanlara da onu
dinleyeceksiniz yapacaksın kulak kapatın
demiyorum Tabii ki dinleyin ama
değerlendiren Lütfen bu konuda size
sanat yapmak anlamında yeniden
yüreklendirmek istiyorum Bu tamamen
yanlış olduğunu düşündüğüm bir yaklaşım
Çünkü güzel sanatlara girerken
üniversitelerde ve liselerde böyle bir
sınav yapıyorlar gördüğünü nasıl benzeri
çiziyorsun sınavı o alıyorlar bu kötü
bir şey değil Burada gördüğü benzetilmek
Kesinlikle kötü değil şunu veriyor
ellerini hakimsin Ama herkes yapabilir
yetenekle ilgili değil
kapatırken şunu söylemek istiyorum
Lütfen lütfen ama lütfen unutmayın Bende
olan başkasında Olmayan şey en güzeli
hepiniz Var Sevgiyle kalın kolay gelsin